on va réduire les GS de 37 et demi pour
cent si 2030 de 100% d'ici 2050 est-ce
que la CAC est sur la bonne voie pour
atteindre ses objectifs de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre
[Musique]
non depuis quelques années les émissions
de GES sont en augmentation au Québec
[Musique]
elles étaient de 87 mégatomes en 1990
qui est l'année de référence pour les
cibles climatiques elles ont ensuite
augmenté puis ont commencé à descendre
au milieu des années 2000 en 2016 elles
étaient de 81 négaton mais elles ont
grimpé à 84 en 2019 au final de 1990 à
2019 les émissions ont baissé d'appel
2,7%
il y aura donc beaucoup d'efforts à
faire si la CAQ veut les réduire de
37,5% d'ici 2030 et encore plus pour les
réduire davantage comme le propose les
libéraux les pékistes et les solidaires
depuis 1990 les émissions ont baissé de
23% dans le secteur industriel et de 25%
dans le secteur résidentiel et
commercial
par contre elles ont augmenté de 12% en
agriculture et de 35% dans le secteur
des transports
même si le nombre d'automobiles à
grimper sur nos routes leurs émissions
totales ont baissé de 17% parce que les
petits véhicules sont de moins en moins
énergivores le portrait différent pour
les camions légers
depuis 1990 résultat les émissions
polluantes des fourgonnettes des
camionnettes et des véhicules
utilitaires sports ont grimpé de 158%